yeah it's just and it makes me upset at
the other people too it's like you don't
you you guys might actually be worse
because you they think he thinks that
you're good friends but you don't like
them and you keep inviting them out so
you might be worse than him at least
he's oblivious and he's a [__] idiot
you know what I mean yeah like you guys
keep inviting in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast I am
your host David cell and we have our
reoccurring host Ed Park VP what's up
guys everybody so
you catching up on anything any movies I
haven't seen [__] I haven't seen Dick I
I usually watch what at least like two
or three movies a week yeah I haven't
been able to watch anything in like in
three weeks it's been kind of weird uh I
did start there's a John boyega and um
Jamie Foxx movie on Netflix they clone
Tyrone yes yeah I haven't seen that yet
I saw the first 10 minutes I had to turn
off because movers are coming in yeah
from the first 10 minutes looks pretty
[__] good okay so I'm excited to to
watch that yeah sci-fi thriller type of
deal I saw Elemental
the new Pixar film so that's okay so
Elementals fasting right because they
didn't know promo for this at all
whatsoever promo was asked dude the
marketing was [__] what happened with
that like Disney [__] the bed with the
marketing like the one marketing I saw
was somebody recording the theater
screen right and this is from the
official Pixar Twitter by the way
they're showing someone bootlegging the
movie but then when that little kid the
character did you see it
well there's a there's a kid that is a
plant kid and then when the text says
every time this guy comes on screen and
then the theater cheers right and it
sounded so fake it was like a it was
like a a staged like screening of people
like cheering for this guy because when
you watch the movie he's [__] nobody
like nobody gives a [__] about this kid
right the movie itself is awesome it's
amazing it's directed by the
korean-american Peterson
um he's the guy that they modeled
Russell after oh okay okay okay okay so
um he wrote the movie based off his
parents like immigrant experience and
his growing up in America with immigrant
Korean parents so when you see the fire
Clan it's it's kind of an amalgamation
of a lot of Asian like cultures but it's
very very Korean of course yeah it's
very angry all the time yeah they're
angry and then they they have these
little nuances that as a Korean like you
you you really relate to it other than
that yeah the [__] marketing was such
[__] that
um people assumed it was gonna bomb
because it didn't do well the opening
weekend it was like their lowest opening
weekend ever for Pixar yeah but after a
few weeks it was this Disney's highest
rating animated film sits I mean
grossing animated films since Frozen 2.
really yeah so over time Word of Mouth
people kept saying No this movie is
actually good and then start seeing it
pretty [__] awesome because I think
I'm getting really tired of films that
are doing well just because the
marketing is great right so most people
are kind of forced into a narrative to
like a film just because you know
marketing did their job yeah right so
when you hear about films that do well
simply on its Merit it's pretty amazing
it's the same thing that happened with
everything everywhere all at once right
nobody really was talking about it until
they actually went to the theater to go
see it yeah and then because of word of
mouth and I feel that obviously
marketing has existed four films for a
very long time but it's become very
Advanced now
um but now when you when you when you
see a film do well that supposedly is
supposed to fail simply because people
enjoy it that's amazing that's that's a
the beauty of like Cinema culture coming
back since the pandemic because it doing
that well because think about it frozen
had a lot of marketing behind it yeah
specifically Frozen too it had so much
Market Frozen two Frozen the original
one apparently because Muriel used to
work for Disney
uh Disney actually didn't expect it to
do well at all yeah they were actually
shocked so when this happened everybody
was scrambling to figure out why they're
like what the [__] this is like the
biggest thing that we've made ever yeah
and so when Frozen one blew the [__] up
I I guess like internally they were
trying to figure out this algorithm like
okay what about this was so amazing that
people enjoyed so much and so obviously
Frozen two became a hit but there was so
much marketing behind it and it already
had a successful hit from the first one
yeah so to hear Elemental kind of had
that same amount of success and still
nobody talked about it which is
fascinating yeah yeah that is doing that
it did that well and I haven't heard a
single thing about it dude uh miyazaki's
new film it's his last film
he's retiring for good finally yeah
finally after he said he was a good
return yeah but the crazy thing is in
Japan they spent zero dollars marketing
no commercial no ads nothing right just
the word that this is miyazaki's last
film and it broke Japan's box office
records that's amazing yeah recently so
they're planning on releasing it later
in America but I can't see how
without any marketing in the US to say
this is miyazaki's last film to get
people to go watch it that was the same
thing with uh Susan so when I saw it I
was actually hardly anybody in the
theater but when you look at the box
office numbers yeah the 300 million plus
damn yeah I was like oh [__] that means
internationally it did well in Japan it
did really really [__] well yeah so
like anime is such a big thing in Japan
it's unreal like when we went to the
theater there uh walking by I didn't go
inside but half the posters are actually
anime films yeah like half the theaters
half the films that's on there on the
big screen is anime anime yeah [__]
blew my mind so it's actually something
that's not just like a niche thing that
people kind of picked up here picked up
on here in America it's actually pretty
consistent in Japan like it's a part of
everything you see them posters you see
it on subways you see Pokemon [__]
everywhere yeah as racist as that sounds
like you see Pokemon everywhere in Japan
okay speaking of anime movies so the the
first the slam dunk is coming out in
America this weekend so I'm planning to
watch that slam dunk is Japanese though
right Japanese yeah see I didn't know
that as a kid really oh because you only
saw the monitor yeah I thought it was
Korean that's because the Korean Mana if
you realize they actually edit it to
make it look less Japanese because you
know how there's like moments where they
do really funny chippy [__] yeah yeah
there's a part when he's trying to
distract one of the guys and he has a
Japanese flags but in the Korean Mana
they just black that out it's just White
Flags that's so [__] funny dude
that's so it's like yeah I mean I've
I've definitely it's hard to watch
American animation or other animation
outside of Japanese 2D stuff because
it's just that much better you know
specifically just how they shade and
color things too it's so different and
even just the composition is better so
if you look at American anime it's
actually Korean animated yeah so there's
a new Superman show
right on HBO Mac or it's just called Max
now and it's the anime Superman it's
Korean animated oh really yeah but and
then he made Lois Lane Korean
why I don't know but that's literally I
haven't seen the show but then just on
the Twitter feed was Lois Lane is Korean
the only two Asian people that's mad
about representation
how [__] dare you change her name
yeah why is it Lois Lane you should be
Lois Lane
I guess her dad was in the military
speaking of representation
Oppenheimer which I saw last week and
it's amazing we'll talk about it
sometime but if you're on you know the
social space and what everyone's talking
about because of the barberheimer you
know hype all of that
you know originally there was like this
immense popularity with hey we're gonna
go see both yeah right instead of them
competing against each other because the
whole thing with it coming out on the
same day is Warner Brothers taking
revenge on Christopher Nolan for leaving
their Studio
Nolan was so pissed at what how they
marketed and released tenant and it
being one of his worst uh grossing films
he and the way they did it in the
pandemic that he was like you know what
I'm I'm leaving and he went to Universal
and made this so Warner Brothers
purposely released on the first day
on my own same day well
you know contrary to that there was an
overall positive vibe of hey we're all
going to see both and then the barber
and Heimer memes and all of that right
but now that people have seen it now
you're seeing the extremes of both sides
talking [__] about it so you have like
conservative like far right saying how
how Barbie is like the fall of our
civilization and [__] was there [__]
uh what's his name Shapiro oh yeah the
Ben Shapiro do a review on it yeah he
always does reviews on pop culture stuff
which is like the Japanese on it it's
like who cares what you think yeah like
you're talking about hip-hop is actually
uh I I'm a classical jazz musician so I
I play the violin so I actually know a
lot about music and um what hip-hop is
it's just it doesn't make sense it's not
music yeah it's not it's not music i i i
i i i holy disagree and uh logically it
doesn't even make sense he's like are
you being a contrarian or are you just a
[__] dork he said you know dork it's
like that's the dorkiest thing I've ever
heard in my life did you see him like
because there was you know a Home Depot
or Lowe's like backlash or some [__] and
so he's like you know as a man and I'm
gonna support you know like Lowe's or
whatever so he goes lows and he buys one
two by four
what are you gonna do with a piece of
wood dude
just the one plank it's like go and
support your local hardware store what
the [__] the [__] are you talking about
dude let me tell you something here Ben
Shapiro you like you closed the door
with your hips you little [__]
shut the [__] up dude I'm here at Home
Depot and guess what does this support
America I bought one two by four yeah
for what what are you gonna do with it
you [__] dweeb and then then this
past week I guess he burned a bunch of
Barbie dolls why why why do you why do
you have Barbie dolls you and bought
Barbie dolls or are they your kids
Barbie Dolls you bought well you already
just supported Barbie yeah
dumbass well the other side of that too
with the far left are people complaining
that Oppenheimer was a bunch of white
people and that there were no Japanese
people in it now I gotta ask did you
actually because I didn't see it I
didn't see that's that's what it's about
but that's kind of
weird because
it's about
exactly it's about the Manhattan Project
in New Mexico yeah no so though I didn't
I maybe I was the only one I didn't
expect to see any Japanese people it's a
historical film in America what do they
want to see a bunch of Japanese people
getting bombed yes that's what I was
surprised by so I even put up a poll
like so 40 of people actually expected
to see people get blown to Smithereens
why
that's not what the movie is about yeah
it's like you're so you're gonna have
the first two films be like this
scientific like genius thing of a group
of like incredible like America's best
who by the way I guess seven of eight of
the top scientists there were Jews you
know
and then people were complaining that it
was just all white men
and so that's the backlash is getting so
this is like the equivalent of
somebody doing like a historical film
like for example when Django came out
right yeah and then people were like I
can't believe they were saying the n
word
it's a movie about slavery dude yeah no
[__] like what are you what are you
talking about or they would get mad when
um it would be about like I don't know
it's like getting mad at Braveheart that
there was only Scottish people in there
he's like what the [__] are you talking
about so it's okay it's like this like
um The Last Samurai right it's about Ken
Watanabe but then they confuse it for
the last time of my being Tom Cruise
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know I mean I
mean the way they marketed with Tom
Cruise on the posters and it says The
Last Samurai you think that Tom Cruise
is The Last Samurai yeah but what it's
really about is is how America broke
Japan's 200 year isolation and they
forced them to start trading right and
to open their borders and their docks
right and America did that so they could
trade weapons in America modernize Japan
they gave him a [__] fast forward
that's why in the first scene they
didn't know how to use the guns and they
got obliterated by the samurai yeah
until the end of movie right
now I didn't see that and be like why
weren't there any Koreans yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know because
America modernizing Japan is what caused
the annexation of Korea not once did I
even think about oh well where are the
Koreans and what they did with those
guns and whatever you know it's like
that's what happened historically
but that's not what the [__] movie's
about yeah and this is like a problem
with sometimes when representation gets
out of hand right it's like you want to
be represented everywhere even where it
doesn't make sense and I don't want to
be represented in those spaces right I
want to be represented in in the parts
where it makes sense so if the if this
like well I'm trying to understand maybe
I'm missing something but do people
literally so what you just want there to
be a scene where there's a Japanese
person like oh
yeah
that's so funny
what did you want
just yeah that's what people are
expecting I'm like what it's I did you
not learn about the Manhattan Project in
school I mean like there are some
legitimate gripes I'll be honest like
the fact that they actually took land
away from natives in New Mexico and Los
alos Los Alamos to to do the project and
then how a lot of native people got
exposed to radiation they they could
have probably brought that part in but
that's also something that makes sense
yeah but that that's a legitimate gripe
but they're literally just saying that
there's no Japanese people but where
where why okay maybe in internment camps
but were there internment camps in Los
Alamos no the whole movie is in
oppenheimer's perspective
right um no spoilers but um if you see
it in a trailer too there's some black
and white scenes and then there's color
scenes right
and the color scenes are oppenheimer's
perspective and anytime it goes out of
his perspective is when it goes black
and white
so that was an artistic choice for it
you know and so it's clearly showing
it's about this one man
you know but then even one this one
tweet
says people seem to love Oppenheimer but
I'll just say it I was uncomfy watching
yet another movie about tortured white
male genius when the victims of
atrocities glossed over by The Script
like what the [__] first Oppenheimer is
Jewish yeah
if it's like you're uncomp it makes you
uncomfortable to watch white people on
screen
like like I said people have problems
with Reverse Racism the term of it but
to me just looking at that straight up
like there's something wrong with you
but what's the point of that of that
commentary though like I don't
understand what the point of the
commentary so I was curious about this
person right her name is Lee Lai
um she is the head of this
um review page a website for movies but
they only Create TV and films on
diversity not on the script
not on the compositions and and and what
the DPS work not on the editing not on
the directing not on the acting it's on
diversity
and then you know what they are actually
their scores actually get affected into
the Rotten Tomato [__] consensus oh
you must be a Shang tea lover for sure
that isn't that [__] crazy that's so
[__] dumb so they there was a World
War One movie that they reviewed and I
got an F
[Music]
there was no other different races it
was just white people and then the
that's not a parody account that's yeah
the subline of it is is it time that we
can start casting people of color in
historical films like World War one
historical people historical what are
you talking about so I'm like okay I'm
just gonna [__] dismiss this entire
like let me tell you something as an
Asian person if I was watching Knights
of the Round Table and I saw a Korean
guy as one of the guys I'd be pretty
upset I'm like that doesn't even [__]
make sense at all no [__] way that
makes absolutely no [__] sense and so
we've said this before like I don't want
to see Asian people in Lord of the Rings
either yeah and also too by the way like
I don't want to see a white person in
like a like a Korean historical film
yeah or just a white person comes out
he's like yeah I'm not gonna want to see
that [__] like this that was a problem
with like uh Marco Polo like for me it
was such an awesome show but it's shot
in the perspective of Marco Polo the
white guy but it's about
yeah you know and I think that's
probably why like it didn't do so well
because it says Marco Polo who wants to
see that but if you said Genghis Khan
yeah I think that would have been a lot
more interesting because he spent so
much money on that [__] yeah like I I
love that first season it was supposed
to be the Asian Game of Thrones right I
[__] loved it I thought it was
amazing it was awesome like the way how
like you saw so many different
historical Asian cultures under one
Banner because that's what Genghis Khan
did right you would never see that today
yeah but it was like he forced them into
like just being a unified empire you
know for so
just to go back on that marketing topic
too when we were watching like uh oh
wait did you have another comment on
that you wanted to read
um there was another one where
they were saying how
no women come and speak
okay fun fact no women speak until 20
minutes into Oppenheimer and then within
a minute there's a sex scene genius
right listeners this podcast is brought
to you by Mint mobile my friends if
you're like me and you deal drugs you
need another phone just kidding I don't
do that but I have a great phone that I
use and I use it with mint mobile
because mint mobile makes me very happy
and I like the fact that it's just
teen dollars a month and I'm talking
about unlimited talk texting data for
just 15 did I say 15 bucks a month how
many times can I say 15 bucks a month
that is absolutely nothing that's two
drinks at Starbucks per month for you to
be able to talk to your friends uh chit
chat away with your girlfriend or your
boyfriend or whoever or whatever you uh
I don't know identify with your your
bears and your furries I don't care the
point is that I have a reliable reliable
wireless service that I can use so I can
chit chat my problems away to get your
new Unlimited Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month my friends you gotta go to
Mint mobile and get the plan shipped to
your door for free so you don't have to
go anywhere mint mobile is here to
rescue with premium Wireless plans for
once again just 15 a month ditch big
Wireless with mint Mobile's limited time
deal and get premium premium wireless
service for just 15 a month so once
again to get your new Unlimited Wireless
plan for 15 a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com genius15 that's
mintmobile.com genius15 cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com genius15
genius brain listeners my lovely genius
farts have you ever been on the hunt for
a new doctor and you asked literally
everyone you know for their Reco you
know a doctor who actually gets you
listens to you and makes you feel super
comfortable and finally after weeks of
searching you find the ones so you call
their office and they have an
appointment available heck yeah but then
the receptionist tells you this perfect
doctor doesn't take your insurance will
wipe your freaking stupid tears away put
away the ice cream and head over to
ZocDoc to find and book the Doctor Who
is right for you and takes your
insurance listen genius brain has been
sponsored by ZocDoc for quite a while
because I love ZocDoc talk Doc is the
best my friends don't listen to your
buddies out there who are saying like
listen I know why you have the wart on
the underside of your penis I've had
that for years this is your solution
They Don't Know Jack nothing you got to
go to ZocDoc and find a professional
that knows why you have bumps on your
penis I am bump free now because ZocDoc
has been there for me you listen to all
these Health upsets folks but when was
the last time you went to an act actual
good doctor or Tesla guess what if you
have to think about it it's time to head
to ZocDoc there are thousands of
top-rated doctors on Stock Doc they're
all listed with verified patient reviews
so you can find and book A Doctor Who
not only has years of experience and an
actual medical degree but also gets you
my friends go to zocdoc.com genius and
download the ZocDoc app for free then
find and book a top-rated doctor today
that's zocdoc.com genius zocdoc.com
genius
look
the thing about film is too like you can
create your art however the [__] that
you want
right nobody ever talks about that right
you created however the [__] that you
want we as an audience have have an
ability to watch it or not that's the
thing you don't have to [__] watch it
at all you literally don't these people
that are advocating that people don't go
and watch it
because of white people
I'm tired of this type of stuff too like
I think
I like speaking up for things when it
counts and it matters right when people
who do this type of stuff you actually
don't do anything for us at all because
it's like the you know the classic Fable
you're the boy who cried wolf like you
keep calling [__] on things that
aren't [__] people just aren't going
to care anymore we just look like a
bunch of whiny ass people yeah so it's
like
yeah when
uh stop Asian hating what's happening
right you saw people who were Elders who
were getting beat up yeah those are
things that we should speak up on right
yeah if it was a film you know where
obviously Asian people can fit in then
yeah let's let's ask for a little bit
more representation right yeah if it's a
bunch of kids in a school in Los Angeles
and everybody's white yeah
you better put some Mexican people on
there's amazing people all this other
stuff right those type of things make
sense especially where I want to be
represented or like in Asian stories or
even just in daily life stuff but when
you talk about something that's like
like a semi-autobiographical right what
do you what are you trying to change
here you're trying to change
history just because you wanted to suit
your idea of what representation is
that's the dumbest thing ever yeah we
can be represented in a lot of places
where it makes sense it's not just for
your idea of what of what you know
fairness is you know what I'm saying
like I don't get it so it's it's really
[__] up the way what it was before
when everyone's like yeah let's watch
both now you're seeing this split and
like once again though it's the internet
you're gonna hear the extremities of
both sides being the loudest voices yeah
and I just just pray for all of you guys
yeah great for sales huh just ignore
that [__] watch both okay like I'm gonna
go watch Barbie tomorrow you know and
then like and else we can talk about it
you know but don't just not watch it
because white people that's [__] to
me that's racist like the amount of
marketing that went into Barbie to me is
unreal because like I've I've seen
people like they set up this whole stand
where you get the yeah Barbie doll
that's [__] unreal yeah I wonder why
they push Barbie so hard because often
Heimer that's so [__] oppenheimer's
marketing is just the trailers in the
film right and because of the the
writers and actor strikes the the actors
can't even promote the film now oh
that's right so it's all word of mouth
it's all Twitter they're they're waiting
on but like I think I mentioned before
like Barbie had like 150 million dollar
budget as a film and then they spent
another 150 million on marketing that's
[__] unreal dude yeah did you see
they built a home in Malibu that was
just all pink too that's crazy they have
pop-ups in Santa Monica and they spots
of like Barbie's heavy ass [__] yeah
there's so much Barbie like marketing
and so it's like you know then
go watch it if you like it you know get
into it if if that was your life what is
the reason why Ben Shapiro doesn't like
the Barbie thing at least it's just like
a feminist agenda and then all the men
are dumb you know and and antagonistic
and whatever but from what I'm hearing
because I haven't seen it yet was that
it's literally The Lego Movie for Barbie
where it's just the unit Barbie Universe
you know so from what I heard it's a
meta modern commentary so I'm excited to
watch it because it's one of those genre
films you know because it's bringing
Barbie into the real world from her
uh mindset and her manufacturing purpose
you can see kind of like Toy Story yeah
and but when they experience like what
the real world is world is like Barbie
has like an existential crisis you know
so I'm curious I'd love to see that yeah
now
you know like that's interesting to me
because before Remember The Brady Bunch
Movie
I vaguely so it was about the 90s right
but this family from the 70s living in
the 90s
But like everyone else around them like
they're it's a late
they're they're in Modern Times And they
just see them as peculiar and they just
kind of accept them into society kind of
thing and then
The Brady Bunch family just still
behaved the way they are and they're
always the same characters
now in this day and age it's like
if you were to make a Brady Bunch Movie
people coming from the 70s now it was
like part of the script would have to be
them going through an existential crisis
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but so yeah I mean in any case I'm I'm
really interested in seeing Barbie but
it was a straight turn off for me to
just
hear people like just [__] on both
movies from both sides it's like it
takes the taste out of my mouth because
who are you hearing from Barbie fans
[__] on Oppenheimer Oppenheimer fans
[__] on Barbie and it's like let's
cut that [__] out well I wonder how much
how many of them actually watched it too
right right that's another thing like
it's hard to get tickets to these These
are selling out really hard like for
Barbie
um they're playing like at the Grove
every 15 minutes damn they're playing in
multiple multiple screens so you're not
gonna miss it but if you want to watch
Oppenheimer and IMAX you can't get
tickets until like the second week of
August the third week of August that's
[__] great yeah that's how far ahead
of it is especially if you want to watch
70 millimeter so I watched 70 millimeter
Thursday morning
yeah it's like that I didn't realize how
it was sold out like that it's all that
if you try to find a 70 millimeter
screening iMac screening good luck dude
the whole
like Rider strike we were talking about
it on uh dudes behind the flutes a
little bit but I haven't really been
looking into anything lately because
I've been so busy doing my own the
office of the [__] but the writer
strike is so fascinating because I just
found out on the previous podcast where
it's like literally childhood petty [__]
of them cutting down trees
yeah Universal trimmed all the trees
where the picketers were gonna stand
right before the hottest week that is
the summer the most childish [__] I've
ever heard in my [__] life from
adults oh they got in trouble
yeah you can't just chop down [__]
public property like that it's not
supposed to be like that if you're a fan
of legal advice on Reddit tree laws is
the [__] really people have to pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
cutting down a tree illegally that's
[__] crazy yeah so the city of La are
going after Universal for that I only
know that because uh even in Sacramento
like there's like thousand-year-old
trees or some [__] like that you can't
just [__] chop it up because it's
[__] up your property you have to go
to the city and they get an approval to
get it trimmed or something else like
that and if not it's like a ridiculous
[__] fine yeah there was there was a
story on Washington because there's like
a bunch of millionaires up in this
neighborhood some guy because he lived
on like his his view was being blocked
by these trees so he just cut them all
down right and then there was massive
complaints like you can't just [__]
cut down trees but you just paid the
fine yeah yeah yeah yeah you paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
these trees there's so many people out
there right now that are that are
picketing like I kind of want to do it
because there's a lot of celebrities
that I really want to do
I just want to walk up to like Kevin
from the office and be like
solidarity brother yeah
yeah uh the actor strike is happening
now too right yeah yeah were you part of
sag no I was never I never made enough
money to be a parsec right so the actor
strike is happening now they're in
solidarity with the writers as well
um so they're not allowed to Market any
of the films they're not allowed to talk
about the movies they're in and they're
not allowed to speak on it on social
media at all they can't do interviews on
it you can't go on a podcast to talk
about it there was um
yeah the the verbiage that they're using
is pretty cruel right because they
literally are willing to shout actors to
the point where they're like you just
won't make money and you'll just be
[__] homeless I don't give a [__]
yeah which is so odd that you would
publicly put that out yeah it was a very
very [__] inhumane statement to put
out why would you do that like like
what's the point that's not gonna help
you they literally are quoted saying
like we have to wait for these people to
start losing their homes so they'll
start giving in one executive actually
said that that's [__] nuts yeah these
people have to like starve so
there's actually
um a fund like a sag fund it's separate
from sag so it's a 503 non-profit
the millionaire actors are are donating
to that to help the actors who are in
need Dwayne Johnson gave a seven-figure
donation damn yeah that's crazy that's
how big props to the rock you know for
doing that but Tom Cruise's ass because
I saw a mission impossible too I mean
well it's part seven part one
and that was an amazing film I loved it
right but the week after Oppenheimer and
Bob Barbie comes out and so I think he
was banking on doing his own marketing
to get people to still watch it so first
he tried to take away iMac screens for
Oppenheimer
and they're like no way there's no way
we're gonna
you know your digitally shot film is not
gonna supersede an IMAX film yeah yeah
and so that he filled in that then the
actor strike happened so now none of the
actors can promote the film and he asked
the
um the union if he could if they could
keep promoting his film that's make an
exception for him and they were like get
in [__] line yeah you know yeah
they're not letting him yeah that's so
crazy like
I think from an outside perspective for
people who don't
listen I'm not saying is to go as far as
like oh you should pity actors or
whatever why not because it's an art
right and anything that you pursue in
art
um you kind of Do It For the Love of the
art and if you're just doing it for the
paycheck it's going to be a rough ride
right but at the same time people still
have to be able to live and survive
right and I think the issue is we're not
talking about the people who suck and
don't book at all we're talking about
people who do book consistently and
they're still struggling like a
[__] and they're legitimate
Stars yeah and they win Emmys yeah but
they get paid peanuts yeah despite the
Emmy Awards dude um
what's it
I guess uh squid game right I mean it's
a Korean production right but apparently
Netflix owns all of the characters the
likeness not likeness but like the the
whole IP of it you know so
I guess the the director and writer got
like maybe a few hundred thousand
dollars
but
the squid game itself
grossed hundreds hundreds of millions of
dollars for Netflix
so they own all the merchandising and
all of that too
and it's crazy guys the people those
guys get nothing see this is the thing
right this is the part that's unfair and
I know for a lot of people that are
thinking well that's a hundred thousand
dollars but you got to think about it to
the equivalent that so for example squid
game right what does squid game do it
wasn't just this small film project that
did well squid game actually brought a
lot of people to Netflix yeah like a
[__] ton right and it actually started
this huge wave of them acquiring more
Korean things because it brought a huge
following to them so they made a [__]
ton of money off of that and there's no
residuals for this so for those of you
who don't know what residuals are it's
just basically money that you get on the
back end for depending on the success of
where something shows yeah so when it
was uh previous two streaming it was ad
Revenue right so you get so wherever
they sell the TV whether it's like in I
don't know Finland Switzerland or
whatever what else right
it shows and there's [__] commercials
behind it and then there's money from
that yeah that you will get a residual
and a cut percentage from that but those
days are over exactly yeah so now it's
like a completely what people are trying
to figure out is a restructure right
um this is just on the actor's side so
it's like okay
um I do Netflix and I get let's say a
shitty check we do a whole season I get
[__] fifty thousand dollars and
that's supposed to last me how long
right specifically in Los Angeles
doesn't [__] last you anything yeah
you get fifty thousand dollars taxes
take half of that so you're left with
like 25 30. okay so now you're left with
25 30 000. that doesn't cover your rent
for the year doesn't even cover my rent
right doesn't cover car insurance
whatever else and then you have to go
ahead and book another job which you may
or may not get now that's a part of the
risk that you take when you go into any
type of art right just because you start
painting it doesn't mean you're gonna
start selling ten thousand dollar
paintings right I completely understand
that but what I what I think the
argument behind that now is that okay
this show is now a success it has
brought you hundreds of millions of
dollars now shouldn't you take care of
me right because let's say you're gonna
do a second or third season
I gotta pay my [__] bills yeah right
and so in the meantime let's say even
this side you get locked out because now
you have to prep for the show so you
can't make another paycheck doing
another acting gig yeah so what the [__]
are you supposed to do so the problem
well Anonymous not the problem but I
guess but
all these streaming sites do not give
out their streaming numbers at all you
go on YouTube it says how many views it
has nobody has any clue what any of
these shows actually see like how many
eyeballs are are seeing it unless
they're using marketing like I think
they'd say oh 500 you know million
individual accounts watch squid game
yeah that's a lot of [__] money yeah
you know for that you know like damn
it's a lot of [__] that's billions
yeah you know and they're giving them
nothing yeah for it because it's not
even to the position of like oh okay
well we put up the money we did all this
so we should this to the victor goes and
spoils right it's like no these people
literally wrote and created the whole
concept like it's everything without
them this is literally it would not
happen at all and I you know competent
them fairly yeah you know what I'm
saying like a hundred thousand [__]
dollars right for a show that brought in
hundreds of millions yeah is not
anywhere near here yeah right that
doesn't make any [__] sense to me at
all so like that's the whole problem
right now it's like now we have to talk
about restructures it's like either pay
me big up bigger up front right or
within the contract let's talk about
some residuals for the money that you
will bring in for new subscribers or
whatever else that it is something has
to give right and I like for me as an
actor too let's say if I came in and
they're like okay there's no residuals
but you get a bigger up front cool give
me that then yeah I'll take that I don't
give a [__] to these Executives make 20
to 40 50 million a year
crazy that's that's more than A-list
actors yeah you know and they don't do
anything with you know the production of
it they just make sure that the
shareholders are happy right
um so that's another problem that's
going on is that you know these people
are asking for the minimum let us live
yeah
can you not buy another yacht yeah you
know with a super mega yacht you could
have paid for like hundreds of people to
just live a regular life yeah you know
and and these actors and these writers
can't yeah so now what are they doing
they're trying to go to AI to have ai
writers and then they're trying there's
another thing that is in a lot of
people's um contracts that they didn't
see
they'll take background actors and take
them to this truck right and they do a
3D scan of them so they can just keep
start putting them in all these
different pages no I'm gonna like this
for life
for life that's [__] extortionary
dude yeah
but here's another person actually asked
chat gbt
they asked what would you do better
writing a movie or being a CEO of a
movie studio and chat GPT said being a
movie studio executive is what I'm
better suited for than being being
creative and writing a script of course
like and also too
um
I think there's a big misconception of
what chat GPT is right so chat gbt they
call it AI right yeah it's not really AI
at this point not right yeah it's a
conglomeration of just data that's all
of the internet that's condensed into an
answer that you like it's constantly
learning exactly so it's not giving you
an answer that's relatively true or
false right because it doesn't have that
capacity yet so it just it just compiles
of what's currently out there so if
something is consistently false it'll
just regurgitate that as well yeah so
it's basically a super search engine is
what it is and so when people for
example like you could tell chat GPT and
get all these parameters for a script
and I think I forgot I watched something
where somebody did that it was like the
trash yes trash it was so [__] bad
there's like a chat GPT Seinfeld that's
so funny because there's it gave them
all of the scripts and just like follow
this formula and then so it comes up
with these really weird [__] up
Seinfeld episodes you know but it's not
really Seinfeld like you can tell it's
not written by Larry David or Seinfeld
it's like um like if you ever got into
the Chachi they have like the app on the
phone right and then you could type in a
parameter for like I wrote um
uh Goku from Dragon Ball Z eating a
slice of pepperoni pizza inside a pizza
parlor right and this [__] demon was
drawn it was disgusting I was like
mid-journey yeah I think that's another
program yeah and I was like what the
[__] is this this is not very good at
all I mean it's learning though like if
you see mid-journey now it's pretty
insane and it's that's another thing
like they're stealing artists work yeah
yeah so now a lot of illustrators
especially comic book illustrators
they're in trouble because now Marvel
Comics can just go to mid-journey and
tell they don't you don't need the
illustrator you don't need an anchor you
don't need a colorist yeah it just
doesn't develop the the yeah yeah and
that's that's scary you know like um
there was this Korean artist I forget he
just draws from just straight freehand
and he creates these crazy Kim jongki
yeah he recently died I think yes yeah
and then immediately some [__] took
all his work and then started recreating
it and making new artwork from him and
it's like hey man let people die yeah
yeah let people move on you know and so
that's another [__] up part of what's
going on with AI it's it is thick but
these Studio Executives see that as a
plus and so they're [__] foaming at
the mouth waiting for a real AI well
this is this is what the world is kind
of coming to right like now we're we're
going to start having this conversation
about what is art right because art is
very much appreciated because it's a
skill set that a lot of people do not
have right so it it kind of has this
value to it because I can't do that
right no matter how hard I try I can't
do that what a lot of like AI technology
social media specifically like Tick Tock
find or whatever it allows for people
who are talentless and I'm not saying
this as an insult right some people just
aren't talented yeah but you're good at
other things but in the art space so
non-artsy people can now fake the funk
about being an artsy person right and
they they get they want that Glory that
they've never been able to have yeah and
so a lot of people are okay with art
theft because it's like if I speak up
about it then I can't do this either
yeah so like for example you'll have
people who um
steal online content all the time like
it's it never struck anybody as [__]
weird that you can create original
script idea comedies or whatever and
then the next thing you know somebody on
Tick Tock takes your joke and they get
millions and millions even more than
your joke yeah right but you're the
originator of this joke but nobody gives
a [__] and even when they find out that
it's copier or bitten off they like it
and they copy it themselves yeah and
they're completely okay with it because
they don't have the ability to make
original content so they want to be a
part of this thing called talented and
artistic people without having to work
for it
let's talk about that so our friend
Cassie hope
one of my favorite favorite creators of
all [__] time I love Cassie Hill
super kind super sweet
um and just an amazing designer like a
lot of the stuff that she creates for
her uh clothing brand in the fitness
space called pop Flex yeah
um
it it solves a lot of problems that
people have with traditional sportswear
or activewear that a lot of Brands just
do anyways because it's a set standard
right you have blanks you use it and you
create it and nobody creates solutions
for these issues that a lot of women
have with their clothing
Cassie being somebody who traditionally
is from um clothing yeah right she
designs her own stuff listens to what
her followers ask for anti-camel toe
anti-camel genius as [__] yeah right
does all this stuff and she and it takes
time and effort and Sheen these [__]
trash bag fast fashion [__] companies
comes in takes her [__] idea and does
it cheaper and worse but people don't
give a [__] about quality they just want
the cheaper product yeah and they steal
from her and they don't give a [__] so
recently she put up another post where
she had a conversation with uh these
people in position and Sheen right and
empowering like the president like the
president yeah right and the reason why
he they took down the original stuff
that they stole they already did it once
before was because his daughter was like
a huge fan of Cassie I was like what the
[__] how could you do this to one of my
favorite people on Earth yeah takes it
down and basically like within their
conversation they were kind of alluding
to the fact that oh we're just doing you
a favor but we actually don't have to
take this down
dude you doing that's so [__]
condescending could you imagine yeah
it's like oh yeah we'll take it down but
we're just doing this because it's you
know we're doing this as a favor for you
not because it's wrong it's what they're
losing oh my God so they basically steal
her [__] all of her hard work and she's
a smaller company right she makes good
money of course but it's still a small
person company that's like 20 people on
staff yeah and they're just trying to
obliterate and these fat I [__] hate
fast fashion like Sheen like when you
buy stuff from things like Sheen or um
what's the other one forever like
forever 20 whatever these companies
right they literally steal from [__]
small companies all the [__] time and
H M and whatnot yeah they create garbage
[__] it's literally [__] garbage you
buy their stuff once and it's done
within a [__] week I know because I
bought them all right it's cheap yeah I
bought h m stuff and I'm I wear it it
feels like garbage it feels like [__] it
falls apart I watch it twice and it
falls apart and it's done yeah and so
these companies are taking out people
who really work hard on their [__] and
then you're comparing it's like well how
come your stuff isn't you know 13 bucks
it's like you pay for what you get
that's why like do you think that when
you wear your button up and then after
you wash it once seven of the button pop
up it wasn't made in a sweatshop exactly
like what the [__] are you talking about
so like this stuff happens all the time
people are stealing and it's okay yeah
and I hate it dude have you seen when
people buy [__] from like h m or the Gap
and then when they they open it on the
tag there's a notices please help I'm
held against my will yeah yeah yeah like
that kind of [__] they'll find it in
their pockets like a note and they're
like oh pretty cool
this is one of a kind art piece I
thought it was [__] hilarious because
Jason Chen commented on blogily's post
about that Shane thing and I'm like why
are you mad dude your whole social media
fade is the scene of social media dude
you are the scene of social media man we
always get [__] to this one well he's
not very self-aware at all so I can't
believe they would steal it's like Jason
you literally steal everything steal
everything man you stole my [__]
that's literally what I commented back
on that if you can find it it's like I
said why the [__] are you mad you stole
my [__] and then other people are like
evidence or get the [__] out and I'm
like I'm not gonna respond to that [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
evidence or get the [__] out what are
you talking about yeah but um
that's the weird thing right like I I've
definitely understand this this writers
strike a lot more because this is what
the society that we live in now nobody
art is losing its value every [__]
day right and we see it a lot I
watch any shitty sitcom in the 90s right
that you thought was shitty and then
watch the sitcoms now there's the acting
is infinitely better
it's crazy yeah like the the lines and
the writing is still bad but they
deliver it way better yeah it's like I
watched I got super high and watched
Dawson's Creek yeah
I was watching Dawson's Creek and the
premise of the show is [__]
ridiculous right but the one thing that
I know even the way they speak is
ridiculous but one thing that I notice
is that all those actors on that show
are really good at delivering bad lines
and it blew my [__] mind I'm like oh
[__] like these people were just a level
above a lot of the actors now the the
you know this I wouldn't call them
casual actors right but sitcom actors
right not to say that they're not going
to do anything outside of it yeah but
watch shows like friends or even the
original cast of That 70s Show did you
watch the reboot there's like that 90s
show or whatever I haven't seen it yet
well terrible it's trash nobody's
talking about it the actors on there
they might be really sweet people and
look I'm not saying about you as an
individual but you as an actor have to
understand you're going to be compared
to the original sitcom show right who
still stands till this day they're they
were just infinitely better at acting
and delivering corny lines dude have you
seen when someone took out the laugh
track to The Big Bang Theory no just to
prove that the Big Bang Theory is ass
they they some audio engineer took out
the laugh track and so it's so awkward
and weird when people give a joke and
there's silence and they have to wait
till the laughter dies now yeah yeah
yeah there's no laughing so the pacing
of it is so weird so I I maybe it's
another thing these days like it's
harder for us to accept sitcoms with a
live audience that way unless it's
something like Saturday Night Live
you know like maybe the sitcom format
doesn't work anymore with a live
audience then you know other like just
comedic TV shows dude like it's an
example of me to me it's an example of
me it's an example to me when I see um
when I go to Modern Art Museums 90 of
that [__] is [__] to me yeah I I'm
sorry like if you if you've gone to like
the Louvre or you've seen like
historical art there's like skill
involved in this yeah like the way the
shade the way they've like shaped
lighting all this other stuff just
because you put fancy words to things
doesn't mean it's better yeah I don't
give a [__] I went to art school and I
took these Humanities and art
appreciation classes and literally
eighty percent of the time I'm like this
is [__] [__] but the teacher's
argument is because you feel that way
says it's art and I'm like ah and you
teach art because you couldn't do it
[__] yeah that's why like that guy who
ran up did you see the guy that runs up
and he jumped on a trampoline and he
just drew a line on the wall oh hell no
and then everybody's sitting there
watching him oh God
he runs jumps on a trampoline grabs a
pencil and he just grazes the pencil
across the wall
and just says it makes like this Loop
art that's art like you have got to
[__] be kidding me man I there was
this person uh online that was on
Twitter got mad at me because he's like
a fashion person I saw that
and I was like what because you were
talking about the what's that it was the
Met gal Met Gala right and then all I
said was like somebody this guy was
calling off like how can people not
appreciate this right it's like they
look stupid I was like it's an opinion
it just looks stupid to them and I
remember his
clap back at you was you sound like a
guy who wears t-shirts and shorts yeah
yeah and I wrote back I was like that's
the majority of the world yeah right so
people are going to have it it's like
it's not that deep people are allowed to
think that this shit's stupid as [__]
right and they're like well I'm in
fashion cool that's your Niche people
don't have to agree with it you [__]
weirdo are you gonna walk down in in the
middle of the street wanting a [__]
apple on your head with the [__] with
two nipple tassels like it's it's odd
like what percentage of the clothes that
are made for the Met Gala actually comes
down to the everyday consumer exactly
like point zero one percent of whatever
the [__] they're wearing exactly what
the [__] is gonna dress up like a cat
it's [__] elitism yeah right so
people who aren't a part of that group
are going to look at it like it's
[__] weird what are you defending
here are you defending the fact that
it's like oh this looks amazing no it
does not now I'm okay to say it doesn't
you could think that that's perfectly
fine but for you to be upset that
somebody doesn't like your art is
[__] weird just because you are in
fashion School you [__] card that guy
that you're talking about I recently saw
a tweet from him because it came up on
my feed it's actually [__] hilarious
because he said he went to therapy
because he had this feeling that
everybody in the world hated him right
do you know that it's actually true you
don't need therapy for that it's
actually a fact so he said he came out
of it with like learning to love himself
and then as soon as he was done someone
from a huge publication wrote an article
about him how everybody hates him
people I'm like that's genuinely funny
oh the way he posted it that's so
everybody hates me maybe because you're
an ass yeah right like if people in your
personal Circle think you're a [__]
ass I mean the online online community
is whatever right but if in general
people think you're an ass in your own
space you're probably a [__] ass like
I can understand that I can be a movie
snob sometimes right like I have to
catch myself when I'm like what you
haven't seen it and I have to be like
hey call out to myself right if you
can't handle that yourself then you you
deserve to get [__] [__] on that's so
you know it was such a weird thing it's
like well here's you look like somebody
who just wear t-shirts it's like yes
that's what normal people wear you don't
like wearing t-shirts yeah the floor
just walks around like with a [__]
pheasant on his chest every day you
[__] weirdo shut the [__] up yes this
is I don't know that whole elitism thing
bothers me a lot I mean I've been going
through this whole thing where one of
the reasons why it's been it's been
taking me so long to move is because uh
I've been on my memory condo tip right
now throwing a lot of the stuff that
doesn't spark Joy right and I've kind of
like come to it's like this weird thing
of coming to terms with how and I've
already done this before but now it's
becoming even more solidified in my life
where material possessions to me are
really starting to mean absolutely
[__] nothing yeah unless it has a
function for me and I really see it and
I think what kind of helped me come even
closer to this idea that I've already
been doing now is being in La where
every time I talk to somebody who I
don't know that that has an assumption
of who I am and the space and the circle
that I'm in they either talk about money
what they have or what they do yeah and
I literally could give a [__] [__]
less what kind of car they drive right
because they see like I own a matcha
franchise or whatever whatnot right
immediately they talk about like oh this
is what I do didn't [__] care I don't
care no I don't even know your [__]
name what kind of Rolex do you got yeah
yeah and they're like oh your bottom
though right it's like oh where's you
know you don't [__] like you you
should buy a Rollie or didn't know
they'll say some [__] like that I'm
making a random example but it'll be
something like that and I'm just like I
don't [__] care yeah what are you
talking about is this what you're gonna
die just like I am do you not realize
this all this stuff that you [__] buy
all these things that bring you
temporary happiness which if it makes
you happy that's fine but you can't base
my happiness on the things that you buy
yeah which is a very weird concept to me
and I keep running into this thing
specifically here in this [__] City
yeah dude I just had this conversation
with my Uber driver oh really he's like
yeah are you from L.A and I just said no
I was just like here and there from
Washington whatever and he's like yeah I
he's Armenian so he's like I don't like
La people they're so uh they're so and I
just said fake he's like yes fake and I
was like superficial yes superficial
yeah so it's like yeah other people like
transplants I guess you could say can
can read that [__] it's like it's a
weird culture of like what I got and
what I do and how people have to
convince him how important they are yeah
and even when they do I'm like I kind of
still don't give a [__] dude I had a
[__] lecture somebody recently
because
they kept ending their statement with
this I know what I mean by lecture I'm
not saying like from a position if I'm
better than this person but I've known
this person long enough where I just got
[__] sick of it and they kept saying
this phrase that was getting on my last
nerves and it was
I'm doing this this is this but I don't
but I'm not like you though but I'm not
like you kept saying it over and over
and over and I finally [__] just
snapped and once again this is like I'm
I'm it's hot as [__] I don't want to
deal with any of this [__]
so I look at him I was like why do you
keep saying that [__] at the end of your
sentences and you know like it's getting
awkward in the room oh what do you mean
so I'm just saying like I'm not like
Hollywood like you I was like why do you
keep ending that [__] sentence I was
like you are literally the dumbest
[__] person in this room and then you
know people are cracking up right I was
like let me tell you why you're [__]
dumb right I'm like you keep saying that
[__] phrase is because you think that
when you say that you're trying to
minimize how you actually feel like you
feel you're not doing enough nobody
gives a [__] about what you do in this
room yeah right we're all just trying to
chill here and every time you bring that
[__] up it's [__] annoying that is
like your go-to phrase but I'm not like
you though right so throughout the
dinner as we're talking that's right
this full orders whatever his dish is
right and then I order my dish right
that was like a chicken parmes and let
me get the chicken parm but I'm not like
him though you know what I mean so I
just kept saying the whole dinner
throughout the whole thing he's all
right I get it I was like no you don't
get it yeah Black Mirror then yeah I was
like you see how [__] annoying it is
cut that [__] [__] out dude I was
like nobody gives a [__] you're on this
like dick measuring competition I was
like I understand you're five foot
[__] three you got a Napoleon complex
now shut the [__] [__] up yeah I like I
just got so [__] annoyed
comparison I forgot what the quote was
like it will steal you of your
creativity and your joy yeah like
comparing yourself to others you know
you know like I did a lot of that I
think in my early 20s and whatnot I mean
I fast tracked out of it
um through going on missions getting
actually living off of nothing
um where to this day actually I got a
PS5 a few months ago I haven't touched
it in two months I kind of feel bad for
having it in a sense but through my
therapy I have to learn hey you deserve
this and it's okay it's fine if someone
had all that stuff and they enjoyed it
because whether it brought meaning or
Joy or a sense of reward for what they
do get it enjoy it love it you know and
that's a positive way to look at it but
if you're looking at oh I only have the
you know BMW 428 this guy has an M4 it's
like who the [__] cares yeah and like
this guy specifically lives his life
comparing what he has to somebody else
so whenever he gets something new he has
to mention he has something new right
it's just so annoying and by the way
when I call certain people out
I'm very very careful right because it's
clearly something that everybody agrees
with in the room but nobody is saying it
so like I just refuse to like look time
is limited I don't want to come out to
dinner and be uncomfortable this whole
time because this [__] person doesn't
understand he's gonna be awkward for
everybody yeah and by the way certain
people in that room don't make a lot of
money so for him to constantly bring up
money could you imagine what that makes
the other person feel yeah you know what
I'm saying like read the [__] room
you idiot like what the what the [__]
are you talking somebody who has to say
how much they paid in taxes they're
expecting you to do the calculation by
20 how much money they made it's like
feel bad for me but what I'm really
saying is I make a lot of money and by
the way this person didn't make a lot of
money maybe like five or six years ago
and recently he you know got a really
good job a few years back and so now
he's enjoying the fact that he's making
money but he's doing it by comparing
himself to other people and making
people feel bad that they're not making
enough money I mean he probably saw it
as a race like hey I caught up to you
guys exactly right right and it's like
caught up to what yeah none of us at
this table spoke about money ever we
came out we drink we enjoy we're in each
other's presence that's perfectly fine
and every time he came in after he got
that new job he would tell oh God man
work is so hard like you know like when
you gotta [__] deal with all these
stupid idiots it's like we all we all
work yeah we all work and nobody gives a
[__] bro but he wants to do that so he
could feel [__] important and now
from what I heard from the uh from this
like small group of people it's like
dude he doesn't say that anymore because
it's like and you and I told him too I
was like you know you guys are also
partially at fault you keep letting him
get away with it you enabled it yeah or
you keep inviting him when you don't
like him
all right stop inviting him out or tell
him to shut the [__] up because it sucks
for me too when I always have to be that
person it's like they're like dude there
was a phrase that people used to say in
college when I was in Riverside they
said that I want to get a band that says
what would David do
[Laughter]
because like a lot of people don't have
the boldness or the guts too I'm doing
this every [__] time it's actually
not that frequent it's I I'm very
selective about things it's like I only
do that when if I have a a just beef
with one individual person in the group
I don't say [__] because that's between
me and that person yeah if everybody
agrees and they're getting annoyed and
this is what I don't like is when we
hang out in a group and when that person
comes and after the person leaves they
start talking [__] about them yeah you
invited him
[Music]
nobody told you to invite this guy and
that's that is that must be an LA
culture thing like like he's part of the
the [__] scene or whatever right and
it's like but they're annoying as [__]
yeah it just and it and it makes me
upset at the other people too it's like
you you guys might actually be worse
because you they think
he thinks that you're good friends but
you don't like them and you keep
inviting them out so you might be worse
than him at least he's oblivious and
he's a [__] idiot
you know what I mean yeah like you guys
keep inviting him yeah yeah don't invite
him make it a lot easier because you're
worried about his feelings what's worse
he gets to think that he has good
friends and he walks away and then all
you guys start talking [__] about him to
me and you start griping about him to me
yeah it's like why why do you do this
just [__] nip it in the bud and then
he'll change that behavior if he wants
to stay friends I'll tell you what Me
growing up too I know I was a [__]
and I look back at like all the leaders
and mentors in my life who didn't say
anything and I had to learn the hard way
I got kind of resentful like why'd you
say something yeah if you [__]
knew why don't you say something it's
kind of like when being fat like why
didn't anyone tell me I was fat you know
I look myself in the mirror people are
sometimes worried about individual
feelings which is very kind actually I I
appreciate that a lot but when it
becomes a problem to the point where
like you're inviting this poison inside
into this group simply because you don't
want to hurt their feelings even though
they're destroying the mood and making
everybody else feel bad that's
absolutely pointless yeah and it's
actually fake [__] like just say how you
feel because at the appropriate time
yeah keep it real keep it real and it'll
help the group dynamics so much right
because look at that they're like oh
yeah he's a lot more chill now because
now he's a little he's self-conscious
yeah he's aware that he has these weird
[__] habits and he makes people feel
bad like I said my snapping point at
that point was the fact that he keeps
talking about money for people who don't
make that type of money right so like
for example he did this one thing out of
multiple things that I just talked about
that was actually piling on was when we
were ordering food he goes
disorder whatever like who cares what it
costs right and it's like we know what
you're doing here you know you're saying
that you make a lot of money and you
know so somebody else is this ordering
what they're saying oh why are you
ordering that don't you want this
instead it's like bro oh my God because
it's [__] like 80 for the [__]
steak it's [__] expensive as [__]
yeah right and I know this person
doesn't make that much money right
because I know what they do for a living
and so they're not gonna [__] order
that you know it's not like you're
offering to pay for the whole meal for
the table you're just making this person
feel [__] uncomfortable yeah so now
if in my position it's like these people
are my friends I'm going to do to you
what you're doing to everybody else
especially when it comes to food though
it's like I'm gonna eat what I want to
eat like if I want a [__] Denny's
spaghetti don't [__] judge me for not
getting the Grand Slam yeah right I mean
I got judge that you were there when we
went to a champion Jeep yeah yeah and I
got the beef jump on because you know I
can't have seafood yeah you know and
that person looked me in the eye and was
like what are you a [__] idiot
cause I got the beef jampong I'm an
idiot it's on the menu it's on the menu
why would they offer it also too there
are different variations of like jumping
too you know what I mean like different
variations of foods like you can't eat
it whatever [__] it so it's like jump on
his seafood and they have a beef option
thank God so I can eat with my friends
yeah God that's what I'm saying man like
I think like for a lot of people too
it's probably a habit that's probably
developed like in high school like when
you're into like these four social
situations where you have to be around
somebody because they're just a part of
the group but when you become an adult
you don't have to kick it with anybody
yeah you really don't yeah you know what
I'm saying and then it's like it's
stunted mental growth right it's a
stunted maturity yeah and this
[__] too has to go to a lot of
therapy to figure out why he feels like
he's always less than somebody to the
point where he has to push somebody down
to make himself feel better right right
like that's I just don't tolerate that
[__] because that's like a weird form of
bullying you know what I'm saying and
like I said read the [__] room guy
what are you gonna do I almost can't
wait to see this [__] again
because he already knows I'm gonna rip
into him again yeah Non-Stop and the
funny thing is like when we were eating
dinner by the way I'm gonna tell you all
the [__] details you know he tries to
roast me back and it's like uh oh then
it [__] sparked boom I'm like yeah
it's on that's why it just kept ripping
into him throughout the whole dinner
right until he was quiet and he would
shut the [__] up right and also too he
didn't apologize to the other people at
the table right for any of that [__]
right making people feel [__]
uncomfortable it's just odd I don't like
that type of stuff and if you're out
there too and you want to call people
out on their [__] there's obviously
a nicer way to do it than I did it right
but I just got sick of it because it's
been a long time I probably could have
taken him aside and said like hey you
shouldn't do this but once again I'm
assessing what this person's behaviors
are if I would have done that to this
person he would have got defensive
immediately would have called me [__]
sensitive all right that I'm just joking
around so the best way that I deal with
people like that who aren't self-aware
is I make them feel how they make other
dude and he ain't doing it again is he
[__] I have half of mine to say
your name on this podcast but yeah
there's something a lot of the
one-on-ones won't work because it
becomes a battle between you two yeah
but when they can see that the group the
collective agrees
then yeah then they can either take the
next step to be completely delusional or
just accept the facts yeah and sometimes
too like this doesn't work out like I
remember
um in college when I was in um Community
College I I spoke to somebody who was uh
kind of being an [__] uh
and some people looked at me like I was
being combative even though they agreed
he was an [__] because I was
disturbing the [__] piece so you do
have to take these risks right but I I
had to stay true to myself right and
obviously after this whole situation
some people apologize like yeah I agree
with you it's just like you know some
people are super sensitive it's not easy
confronting somebody it's actually very
[__] difficult and I get nervous
before I do it but sometimes I just
can't take that [__] and I have to say
something yeah you know yeah well guys
that wraps up this episode of The Genius
brain podcast
um you can catch genius print every
Sundays at 12 p.m and uh you can catch
Ed at edpark VP I hope you guys enjoyed
this podcast let us know what you think
in the comments below and we'll see you
all next time peace peace